today on the matt wells show a fully
weaponized fbi raids the home of a
former president and future 2024
opponent is this a totally unprecedented
and shocking turn of events as most
people on the right are saying or is it
a totally predictable turn of events in
a country where all of our institutions
have been captured by the far left also
speaking of captured institutions the
democrats are building an army of irs
agents to make your life miserable plus
a mom looks on and cheers as her child
works the stripper pole at a pride event
that and many other important topics
we're going to talk about today but
first
i want to talk to you about something
you know we started the matt well show
in my car we did the first many shows
just like that it was a low tech
low-tech low-budget lo-fi operation back
in those days talking into a webcam from
1995. i think i had the budget of uh
50 cents of a toothpick basically
and it was just me in a random parking
lot
screaming at my dashboard confusing all
the other walmart shoppers
and the worst thing is that no one ever
told me i had a terrible haircut back
then i don't know how my wife let me out
of the house like that but eventually
she invited me back into the house and
we moved into a home studio
and an odd thing started to happen is
that people started watching and
listening and we started to grow and
eventually we moved out here to
nashville and that's when things really
started to take off over the last year
thanks so much to all of you
we have become the fastest growing
conservative podcast in the country uh
one of the fact one of the one of the
biggest news commentary podcasts in the
country one of the biggest podcast
period we've got the best documentary of
the year we've got a
lgbt best-selling children's book we're
saving abuelas we're saving virginia
we're doing all of that but here's the
great thing we're just getting started
all of that and more today on the manual
show
[Applause]
[Music]
the supreme court decision to overturn
roe was a huge albeit long overdue step
in the right direction but there's still
a long way to go to rid our country of
abortion many companies are bowing to
the woke mob by donating to pro-choice
causes and candidates or reimbursing
their employees travel expenses so that
if they live and work in a pro-life
state they can travel to a pro-abortion
state and get an abortion and be back at
work on monday because that's what of
course these companies really care about
well what if i told you that if you're
currently on a phone plan with one of
the major carriers you might be
supporting these companies and their
pro-abortion agenda with your monthly
phone bill don't let abortionists use
your money to fund policies you don't
believe in switch to charity mobile
instead charity mobile is a pro-life pro
family cell phone company that sends
five percent of your monthly plan price
to the pro-life charity of your choice
you don't have to compromise on values
or good phone service you can get it all
with cherry mobile charity mobile offers
the latest 5g phones no device or
service contracts great nationwide
coverage and live customer service base
right here in the usa the fight for the
right to life continues and pro-life
causes need your support you can help by
simply switching your cell phone company
today to charity mobile call
three six six two 1-877-474-3662 chat
with them online at charitymobile.com
mention offer code walsh to redeem a
free cell phone offer that's
charitymobile.com and mention offer code
walsh
welcome to the matt wall show we
couldn't think of a better way to
celebrate our 1000th episode then by
unveiling our brand new studio this is
an actual
real studio it's not a sheet uh that's
even as a real banjo behind me which as
you know i can really play so we've come
we come a long way and we aren't even
close to done yet but there are um
considerably less joyous events
happening this week across the country
unfortunately
starting with
the news that broke last night that
agents with the fbi 30 of them
reportedly
raided the florida home of former
president donald trump
now news of the raid first came from
trump himself who issued a statement
saying in part quote these are dark
times for our nation as my beautiful
home mar-a-lago in palm beach florida is
currently under siege raided and
occupied by a large group of fbi agents
after working and cooperating with the
relevant government agencies this
unannounced raid on my home
was not necessary or appropriate
trump added that the fbi henchman had
even
broken into his safe though his son eric
reported that they found nothing of
interest inside it but they broke into
it anyway
so what were they looking for well the
new york times passing along the regime
approved version of events says that the
fbi conducted this operation in order to
recover classified material that trump
had allegedly brought to his house after
leaving the white house reading from the
daily wire report it says agents with
the federal bureau of investigation
executed a search warrant monday at the
florida home of former president donald
trump that appear to be connected to
classified material that was allegedly
at the home the investigation is quote
focused on material that trump had
brought to him brought with him to
mar-a-lago his private club in residence
after he left the white house according
to the new york times report those boxes
contain many pages of classified
documents
multiple reports later confirmed that
the raid was connected to the missing
white house records the report said that
trump delayed returning more than a
dozen boxes of material to the national
archives
which included documents that were quote
marked as classifying national security
information
ah so the federal bureau of
investigation
took the historically unprecedented
absolutely unheard of mind-boggling step
of raiding the home of a former united
states president all on behalf
of the national archives
now
leaving aside the fact that other
very prominent former white house
officials hillary clinton comes to mind
have been caught up in scandals
involving their handling of classified
materials and yet never have been rated
by the fbi as a result
even leaving that aside
this explanation makes little sense for
the simple fact that donald trump as
president
could declassify literally any document
he wanted whenever he wanted
as the chief executive that's the power
that he had now does this mean that joe
biden reclassified the documents and
then promptly had uh you know sent the
feds to raid his predecessor's home on
that pretext
well perhaps
but the operative word here is pretext
this of course has nothing really to do
with the national archives or classified
documents um this raid is two things
one it's a fishing expedition in hopes
of turning up something you know a bit
more explosive than an alleged potential
violation of the presidential record act
act and uh and two
this is a shot across the bow this is an
exercise of might this is an act of
political warfare
it's a statement
an announcement that we live now in a
third world banana republic
the fbi along with all of our federal
law enforcement agencies along with the
entire doj
has long since been ideologically
captured by the left
all the complaints about
double standards and so on all that
comes back to this
no the doj won't do anything about
democrat corruption
it wouldn't do anything about hillary
clinton it won't even take a second
glance at the current president's
crack-addled son won't do any of that
it certainly won't prosecute any of the
people in epstein's little black book
have you noticed that
that
um even years later still to this day
none of the people
who were involved in epstein's sex
trafficking
uh business have been arrested or
charged with anything
now
um
the fbi has a long history of showing no
interest in apprehending sex traffickers
especially and serial rapists let's not
forget the agents who knew
that larry nassar was raping the girls
on the olympic gymnastics team and did
nothing at all to stop it
and then later lied about what they knew
the doj always looking out for its own
then declined to prosecute those agents
of course
a few months ago
activists in dc uncovered physical
evidence
that an abortion clinic in the city was
murdering fully developed children
already born fully developed children
this is infanticide
the systemic systematic slaughter of
infants
the doj refused to investigate
no fbi raid was conducted
maybe they'll wait 30 years like they
did with kermit gosnell before they
finally decide to look into that into
the situation
the doj has no interest in any of these
crimes
but it'll bring down its wrath on its
political enemies starting with trump
but certainly not ending with him
i mean at least trump has money and fame
and a loyal following
all things that give him some amount of
protection no though obviously not
complete protection
the pta parents recently labeled
domestic terrorists by this same
department of justice don't have any of
that insulation
and so we see that
as a consequence of the ideological
capture of the institution
we cannot really say that there is a
double standard because there is in fact
one standard
they will try to destroy you if you
oppose them politically
that's the standard that's the
overarching principle that the fbi and
and and all the rest of the federal law
enforcement agencies believe in
and they actually follow that prince
that principle with rigid consistency
but here's the point this goes far
beyond the department of justice
the fact is that all of our institutions
are being held hostage by the left all
of them
they are all being eaten alive from the
inside by the same disease
every institution from academia to the
medical industry
to the churches and everything in
between
one cannot help but uh but take note of
the timing of this raid actually because
it comes only a day
after the democrats passed the bill
which would see the irs doubled in size
with 87 000 new agents hired
if there was ever any question about
what this new fleet of tax goons will be
doing well i think those questions are
answered now after what happened at
trump's house
they will be focused just as they were
under obama on tracking harassing
pilfering and plundering from the
enemies of the regime and from the
middle class generally which the regime
considers its enemy
this again
is how every institution operates in
this country every single one
they all have their guns whether literal
or figu figurative or both
pointed in the same direction pointed at
us
so what can we do about it
well here's what we don't do
we don't simply whine about double
standards and then just leave it at that
as if we've achieved something merely by
calling our opponents hypocrites as if
the charge means anything to them like
they care
if you if you haven't noticed when you
say to the left oh you're a bunch of
hypocrites they don't care
doesn't mean anything to them
you know we don't um
we don't do that
we don't become impotent fatalists and
doomers
naysaying all efforts to improve our
situation insisting that nothing will
ever get better all is lost woe is me
etc we don't do any of that what we
should do instead
is fight back with a ferocity intensity
and ruthlessness
that may have seemed distasteful to
conservatives in years past
and some conservatives even still today
but they're gonna have to get over their
squeamishness
part of that fight though certainly not
the whole fight but part of it is
political
that means ensuring that the red wave
indeed comes to pass in 2022
but more than simply electing
republicans generally we must
specifically elect the sort of
republicans who have the gumption to act
decisively and wield their legal power
actually use it rather than talking
about using it actually use the power
that they have
and and and to do so in service to what
is good and just and true
we need the kinds who will
do all this in spite of the sustained
attacks they're going to face
now
i realize that the list of republicans
who fit this qualification is uh
somewhat
limited but this is the sort we must be
looking for
and once they've taken power we must
push them
to do more than hold hearings and
assemble committees and all the rest of
it
what we want to see we need to be very
clear about this
is corrupt government officials arrested
okay so you can you can
have your hearing if you want if it
makes you feel better but we want to see
people in handcuffs arrested and frog
marched in front of cameras
we want to see entire agencies gutted
and disassembled
we want to see a demolition derby
metaphorically speaking
and we should be very clear about that
now let's get to our five headlines
you've heard me talk a lot on this show
about how important it is to get your
kids away from the public school system
and main and also mainstream kids
content marxism socialism critical race
theory and trans ideology all of that is
what we have to deal with the left is
pushing a persistent and loud attack on
truth and they're starting with your
kids there are a lot of ways you can
protect your kids from these
not-so-secret leftist agendas you can
homeschool you can get them involved in
a religious community you can give them
the right books to read like my
best-selling children's book johnny the
walrus but one of the easiest and
simplest ways to protect your children
is to take five minutes tonight to write
a will with epic will a will gives you
the power to say who will raise your kid
should something happen to you and your
spouse it can in certain cases be the
only legal defense standing between your
kids and the persistent indoctrination
attempts from the left epic will is an
online wheel platform that costs less
than your next trip to the store they
can set you up with a will in as little
as five minutes and they can start at
119 dollars that's it plus you can save
10 you go to epicwheel.com and use code
walsh take five minutes tonight to write
a will ensuring that your kids will be
raised the way that you've intended in
the event that something happens to you
go to epicwheel.com and use my code
walsh today
well as mentioned the democrats passed
on sunday their 740 billion dollar
inflation redoubling act uh part of this
bill
i mean the whole thing is a disaster
obviously but the worst part is like we
talked about the 87 000 new irs workers
that will be hired
because of this um and this is the
democrats big election season push this
is their grand idea okay
heading into the midterm elections this
is what they've come up with
when we've got inflation the economy is
in shambles
um people are living in cities you know
afraid to leave their homes because of
crime is running rampant and everything
is falling apart and the democrats their
their pitch to the voters heading into
the midterm elections is oh we're going
to get more irs agents and audit you
but they say that this is um that it's
not what it appears to be right it's uh
it appears to be a war on the middle
class
hiring more stooges to audit and pilfer
middle-class middle-class americans no
they say it's not that the irs will
focus on
on rich people they say
except the problem is that every
democrat voted against an amendment
requiring that the new irs agents only
audit companies and people who make over
400 000 a year so they could have put
that into the bill and an amendment
saying that all these new irs workers
that we're bringing on none of them are
going to be concentrating
on auditing middle-class
americans and given that the democrats
said that that was this their intention
the whole time was to not do anything
with the middle class then they should
have signed on
the dotted line for that amendment but
they didn't
every democrat voted against it
because
their actual intentions are quite clear
senator ben cardin though of a democrat
of maryland
says that even so okay maybe they're
gonna focus on the middle class maybe
we're all gonna get audited but uh
there's there's still there's nothing to
worry about let's listen to his
reassuring words
can you understand how 87 000 new irs
agents would scare the heck out of
millions of americans
millions of americans aren't going to be
impacted by that other than getting
better service from the irs having their
telephone answer getting the questions
they need in order to comply with our
tax laws the auditing is going to be
focused on those of high income the
large corporations etc so
there's no reason to be fearful and if
you have paid your taxes and if you
comply with our laws you should want to
make sure everyone else does that
ah well what are you worried about if
you have nothing to hide then there's
nothing to worry about
you know if you paid all your taxes
nothing to worry about
as if as if a you know an audit is just
a pleasant
even enjoyable experience if you've paid
all of your taxes
of course there's a very good chance
that uh
uh especially if if your income is not
solely from if if you if you have you
know if you only make w-2 income then
more than likely
you know your audit's going to come back
okay although it's still not going to be
a fun process
but if you have some non-w-2 income then
you know there's there's a relatively
decent chance so you've made a mistake
here or there you've you know you've
whatever you've lost some paperwork or
something
so what what they're proposing here is
that there are like two categories of
people right there are the honest good
people who pay all their taxes and and
uh and every last penny and then there
are the tax dodges and the tax cheats
and who intentionally are
defrauding the irs for millions of
dollars every year like those are the
two categories of course there's a lot
of room in between
and a lot of middle class people find
themselves on the in between area
but again even if you have paid all your
taxes
an audit is a miserable
incredibly stressful experience
there's a reason why it's used you know
it's it's the the term is used we use it
like we use the term root canal just to
just as a as a stand-in for a miserable
that's what that's what the that's
almost the definition of the term now is
a miserable experience an audit
um
but ben cardin says that oh no really
it's just going to be better service
right because that's what you want from
the irs is better service
they're going to answer your phone calls
first of all on the answering phone
calls bit
let me let me just be clear about one
thing
it doesn't matter how many irs agents
they have i mean right now they've got
76 000 people working the irs and if you
try to call the irs nobody's answer
you're not going to call the number that
they have available
that you can find on a website and you
call up irs and someone just picks up
the phone hey irs speaking who's there
so that doesn't happen now you hot you
double the size of the
bureaucracy no it makes service worse
not better
this is something that we've all
experienced that
the bigger anytime especially if you're
trying to get in touch with someone if
you have a problem of some kind
and this goes for government agencies
and also private companies as well
like the cable company or your cell
phone carrier whoever it is
the bigger the bureaucracy
the worse the service the more difficult
it is to actually talk to a human being
the more impossible it is to find
someone who cares about your situation
and especially
the more impossible it is to
find anyone who is accountable if a
mistake is made
because that's part of the reason that's
part of the point behind the enormous
bureaucracies it is to the bureaucracy
grows bureaucracies grow because they're
cancerous tumors and all they can do is
grow right
unless they're given some some very
harsh treatment otherwise they're going
to grow so they grow because that's what
they do but also they grow
in order to insulate
it grows in order to insulate itself
from accountability the bigger
the the more people that there are
involved
then
the more difficult it is to pinpoint who
is responsible for any one individual
thing
and if you're just some sap calling on
the phone then it's going to be totally
impossible for you
so it's quite the opposite
it's not better service when you add
more bureaucrats it is worse service
always every time
but speaking of service you know you
know the service that i want to see
from the irs um
i would like to see the irs
uh disbanded that's the service i want
to see like self-destruction by the all
right that's the to me that's good
customer service
if i call up the irs and they say oh we
sorry we're packing up we we're uh yeah
we're done with this whole thing that's
good service as far as i'm concerned
by the way colin pruitt uh posted this
interesting graphic from 2019
and this is pretty uh this is pretty
i mean this is stark here okay this is a
stark illustration so this shows
where in the u.s you're most likely to
be audited by the irs
and so you can look at it there
and of course the darker
red
than the more the more irs that the more
audits that they have in that particular
region of the country and what you see
is that
it's kind of fascinating
that this is also basically a map of the
red states
it's a this is this almost doubles as a
map of of red states and also a map of
where the most poor people live
uh now there are some exceptions so
there are a good amount of audits
happening over in california would seem
but for the most part
you can see it there then it's nothing
but gray you get up into the northeast
and it's nothing but gray it's
fascinating how the northeast corridor
which is boston new york philly
baltimore washington
not covered in red
even though that's where you're going to
find the densest population in the in
the whole country
that's where you find a lot of rich
people too living
from boston all the way down to dc
not a lot of red there
isn't that fascinating
so the question we have now
i'm heading into 2024
and i go back to what i said in the open
which potential candidate will not just
complain about the 87 000 irs agents
but will actually fire them
not hold hearings i've already heard
we've already heard from republicans
saying they're going to hold hearings
we're going to we had so many hearings
kevin mccarthy said
uh you you guys better you're ready
because when we're in charge there's
going to be some hearings i tell you
what i have all kinds of here we're
going to hear we're going to be hearing
a lot of stuff okay
um no i don't need hearings i don't need
ranting about it i don't need tweets
about it i don't need anything like that
are you going to do something about it
are you going to actually fire these
people
okay it's not going to be difficult to
determine
which of the you know once republicans
are in charge of the government
it's not gonna be difficult to determine
which irs agents are part of the 87 000
crop
are you just going to
boom you're all gone you're all fired
and further than that
which republican is actually going to
start calling for the abolition of the
irs completely
i mean first of all you want to talk
about a popular position to take
you cannot get more popular than that
to abolish the irs
and it only sounds like pie in the sky
unthinkable because we take for granted
that the irs exists and that we live in
a country where there's an income tax
and there's a withholding system and you
know the government they take our
paychecks and they take the bit that
they want of our right to paycheck and
they give us the the remainder so like
they get their hands on our paycheck
before we even do so we take all that
for granted
but it was not always this way
this is a relatively new arrangement
and there are other ways of going about
it it's not as though if you don't have
an irs and you don't have an income tax
then the government has no way of taxing
people
that obviously is not the case you can
go to a consumption-based tax system
which wouldn't necessarily require a
centralized behemoth tax collecting
agency
when are we going to hear republicans
start talking about that that's the
question
speaking of amendments to bills i wanted
to play this for you too uh marco rubio
tried to add his own amendment to a bill
a few days ago and it led to this rather
fascinating exchange watch this
the senator from florida mr rubio moves
to commit the bill h.r
5376 to the committee on
health education labor and pensions
of the senate with instructions to
report the same back to the senate in
three days not counting any day in which
the senate is not in session
with changes that one are within the
jurisdiction of such committee and two
would contain a definition for the term
pregnancy that limits maternal and
infant related program resources to
biological females
mr senator from florida is recognized mr
president the only people who are
capable of being pregnant are
biological females and therefore i think
federal biola federal pregnancy program
should be limited to biological females
and that's what this would do
well thank you mr president um
a few minutes ago i look back
across 5 500 years of human history so
far every single pregnancy has been a
biological female and so therefore the
only thing i'm trying to do is make sure
that federal law is clear that since
every pregnancy that's ever existed has
been in a biological female that our
federal laws reflect that and our
pregnancy programs are available to the
only people who are capable of getting
pregnant biological females very simple
i would accept a unanimous consent if
they want to offer it and we can move on
and not waste any time
senator murray has 10 seconds left
when we are facing the challenges we do
in this country when we're facing
challenges in this country and helping
our constituents to lower costs it is
outrageous that republicans are trying
to define pregnancy of all things on
this floor on this day after hours of
voting on amendments i urge a no vote
outrageous i mean this is outrageous to
def she says we can't we can't define
pregnancy
she says
um now i i think that
i appreciate the effort by
marco rubio and and
at any time the republicans uh take
advantage of an opportunity to highlight
the fact that democrats are a bunch of
anti-science pagans there are a bunch of
lunatics
a gaggle of lunatics who believe that
men can get pregnant women have penises
i mean absolutely take advantage of
every conceivable opportunity to point
that out
that's another hint going into 2022
2024
as i've been saying forever and some
republicans are finally starting to clue
into this though not enough this is a
winning issue uh it's even a it's even a
bigger winning issue than abolishing the
irs although that would also be a
winning issue but uh you know speaking
out against this insanity is a winning
issue
and you're putting democrats in a
position that they absolutely don't want
to be in because what you have to
remember is that
very few of these people though they are
beholden to the radical left though
they've adopted this posture because
they think they have to very few of them
actually believe any of the trans
ideology stuff very few of them actually
believe it
they have to pretend that they do
and they really wish they didn't have to
pretend it they don't like that they
have to pretend that they they agree
with it
like they don't enjoy here's the thing
that you think they enjoy being held
hostage
by the trans militants no they don't
like it
that's the position they put themselves
in
and so any time
we can make them even more uncomfortable
in that position then we should do that
so that part i like
and that's why i appreciate the effort
however i don't think it's semantics to
point out
that you kind of you you ruin
the whole thing
when you use the term biological female
instead of just saying woman
so it should have been an amendment and
obviously it wouldn't have passed this
way either even less likely to pass
but then at least you're making the
point that you want to make
you know if the amendment was to to to
stipulate that maternity services
are only given to women
because only women can get pregnant
then you've made the point that you want
to make
and then you've put the democrats in the
position of having to get up there and
say well no men can get pregnant too
when you say biological female
you you give them a lot of outs first of
all
then you give them the opportunity to
say well there's a difference between by
all of sex and gender and these things
and it's so complex and you can't
possibly understand so you give them
that that out
when you use the term biological female
instead of just saying woman
but also and this is something i have to
constantly remind myself as well
um
because it just becomes a habit to use
terms like this
but when you say biological female
you know it's it it's a qualification
that isn't necessary and it makes it
sound like there are other kinds of
females
well this is a biological female it's
the same mistake that a lot of
conservatives made and still make when
they say traditional marriage as opposed
to other types of marriages
well no because the argument that you're
trying to make is that marriage is a
certain thing it's defined a certain way
and there aren't any other types of it
this is just what marriage is this is
not the traditional form this is not the
biblical form
this is just marriage
and so it's the same thing here
you know if you're saying if you're
saying female biological is not
necessary
it's it's like saying
um
a you know a geometric circle
well
yeah i mean true right it is a
geometric circle fine but that's but if
we're talking about geometry we're
talking about shapes so we don't really
need the geometric part it becomes
confusing it makes it sound like okay a
geometric circle as opposed to what
other kind of circle are we talking
about
so
same thing here and and that's it and it
does it again it might sound like
semantics but it's really not
you have to keep this in
mind you have to think carefully about
the language that you're using
and unfortunately these days our
language
is full of booby traps
because so many of the words and terms
that we use that have been given to us
by the culture
they've been given to to us by the left
and simply by using those terms you're
already surrendering the point that
you're trying to
refute
all right i want to read this is from
the new york times and i haven't really
said much if anything at all about this
story and one of the reasons is that
frankly i just don't care all that much
but
all the same
here's the latest from the new york
times it says immediately after a moscow
judge handed down brittany griner's
nine-year prison sentence thursday calls
grew louder for president joe biden to
find a way to bring her home
the reverend al sharpton said in a
statement we call him president biden
and the united states government to
redouble their efforts to do whatever is
necessary and possible u.s officials and
analysts had been resigned to a guilty
verdict for griner a basketball star who
plays for a russian team during the wnba
offseason but the cult reality of her
sentence on a drug charge was a shock
and renewed calls for biden to secure
her release even as critics fumed that
offering to swap prisoners with moscow
rewards russia and its hostage-taking
practices um the result is a painful
quandary for the bible administration as
it tries to maintain a hard line against
president vladimir putin and uh so on
and so forth now
a lot of people have said that this is
um unprecedented you know for an
american citizen to get this kind of
sentence for having drugs or drug
paraphernalia
in russia you know this is unheard of
and and uh and
you know putin is doing this to make a
political point or he's doing this
because he wants a hostage for a for a
prisoner swap and both those things
might be true by the way it's clearly
part of what he has in mind
but even so it's actually not
unprecedented at all
um have you heard the name mark fogle
and i asked you that because i hadn't
heard that name until just a couple days
ago when i happened to read an article
about this
um mark fogle is an american citizen
currently in in a russian prison right
now
on drug charges 14 years in prison
and this is a recent thing too this is
not from years ago
so this bbc article says a russian court
has sentenced a former u.s diplomat to
14 years in prison for large-scale
cannabis smuggling mark fogle previously
worked at the u.s embassy in moscow but
was employed as an english teacher in
the city at the time of his arrest fogle
was sentenced in the same jurisdiction
that's hearing a marijuana-related case
against u.s basketball star brittany
griner cannabis is legal in many parts
of the u.s but remains illegal in russia
quote the american citizen fogel has
been found guilty a court in moscow
moscow suburb of kim ki said in a
statement the news release said that the
english teacher had committed
large-scale drug smuggling in addition
to large-scale illegal storage of drugs
without a commercial purpose
so how many how much drugs did he
actually have well vote says that
fogel's in his 60s had around 17 grams
or about half an ounce point six ounces
of cannabis in his luggage when he was
caught on the 15th of august 2021
and then it was just
early in the summer actually when he was
um
found guilty and sentenced to 14 years
in prison for this
and for whatever reason
you know we hear all the handwringing
and people are in tears over brittany
grinder the basketball player
but we don't hear much about mark fogle
or any of the other american citizens
for that matter who are
in prisons not just in russia but across
the world
for breaking the law or
allegedly breaking the law in the
countries where they were visiting or
spending some time in
and that's the thing here you know
this is um
what we have to keep in mind that this
is the law in russia
and it has been since forever
and they've been doing this since
forever
where if you come into the country and
you've got drugs and you're breaking
their laws they're going to throw the
book at you this is what they do
because they take drugs very seriously
in that country
now you don't have to like it but what i
can't this is one of the reasons i
haven't said much about this story
because when i first heard about it i
said well
i mean that's unfortunate to do nine
years in prison in russia i wouldn't
want to do that but then again i
wouldn't be bringing any kind
of drug paraphernalia or anything into
russia
because i'm not an idiot
and it's this is russia we're talking
about
this this is not los angeles
and so you must you must at some level
know what you're doing and yet you do it
anyway because i guess you think well
you know i'm brittany griner i'm a wnba
star
if such a term even makes sense well
they're not going to do anything to me
and then you learn that well
actually they don't care about that over
in russia
and as far as their drug laws and i know
that we
have heard a lot about how unjust and
everything the drug laws are
in russia well i should note that
this might be part of the reason why
their overdose fatality rate is a
fraction of what ours is
we have one of the highest overdose
rates in the world
i mean we lead the world that's one of
the categories one of the
unfortunate categories where we are you
know
setting setting that we're setting the
benchmark
in overdose deaths
well not in russia i mean there's his
infinitesimal in comparison to ours it's
a fraction of ours
and yeah we have double the population
that they have
but even taking into account even if we
looked at it per capita
still the overdose rate for them is
quite a bit lower
and
part of the reason for that again is
that they just are not gonna mess around
with this stuff
if you get found with it
you're done and that's it
um
now though
we're supposed to take a lesson from
this and this in fact some people on the
left have been saying that uh well
they've kind of started to make what
sounds like almost the same point and
saying that well why are we talking
about brittany griner
when when in fact there are
what about people in the in the united
states who are in jail on drug charges
so we need to take russia as an example
and do more of the opposite
by making our drug laws even more
relaxed
but i kind of take uh
i i have a very different takeaway i
take i take the opposite lesson away
from this
which is just that if you actually have
i mean it's one thing to say zero
tolerance but if you actually have a
zero tolerance
attitude
towards drugs
and you're waging a real war on drugs
not just saying it but an actual one
then you are going to see some of these
problems mitigated to a certain extent
i mean if you if you punish an activity
and you punish it severely and
consistently you will get less of that
activity that's just a fact of human
nature
all right let's see what else we got
here um
a woman some of the other woman in an
lgbt pride event of pennsylvania cheered
on a young boy working a stripper poll
a video posted by libs of tick tock
shows
photos confirmed the 30th annual central
pennsylvania pride celebration held in
harrisburg on july 30th featured drag
queens and a stripper pole the event
where the shocking video sourced was
taxpayer subsidized
i think we have the video of that let's
play let's play the video here
[Music]
yes sir
[Music]
now this video was posted i think but
the most important thing to keep in mind
here
and to take from that is that the video
was posted by
a concerned citizen who happened to be
walking by and saw this happening
but uh was posted by the boy's mother
and she said uh she was very happy about
this and put it up on tick tock i think
it's been taken down
since then that shows by the way the
bubble these these freaks live in that
she posted this video
and
didn't expect any backlash at all i mean
she's got her
young son on a stripper pole
being taught how to strip by a
almost entirely naked man at a gay pride
rally and she thought that she would get
nothing but high fives and smiley emojis
in response and she got some backlash
and then she deleted it
so she posted it and she said
central pa pride had a poll set up with
an amazing instructor to assist my kiddo
is a natural
you know we hear about the groomers in
the public school system we hear about
groomers and the media and academia and
hollywood and all these other
institutions
and um it is true that all these
institutions do have a grooming problem
no question about it
but the really dark reality is that
there's also a grooming problem in the
institution of the family
in many of these families that's where
the grooming starts
and it's really unthinkable to those of
us who are normal decent people it's
like just unthinkable
that
a parent would engage in this kind of
activity a parent would groom their own
child in this way but that's what the
lottie's parents do
which is all the more reason
why the good guys
have to step up and speak up
for these kids because they have no one
i mean what what what chance or hope
does this kid have
that this is the environment he's in
this is what his mom is subjecting him
to
i mean someone should have showed up
and and i get if you're a normal person
you don't even want to walk through an
event like this but
were there no
just bystanders who happen to be walking
by and would have seen this and could
have just went over to that stripper
pole and knocked it over and said you're
not doing this here
this is not going to happen
i'm not going to allow you to do this
you're not putting kids on a stripper
pole you freaks
that's what we need
someone to step up
lots of us to step up actually
let's get now to the comment section
do you know their name
according to feeding america one in six
children experience food insecurity food
is obviously important to busy students
studying playing and practicing all day
before heading home with rising
inflation food security could get even
worse over the coming weeks and months
our friends of good rangers won't stand
idly by while america's children go
hungry but they need our help that's why
they're on a mission to donate 100 000
high quality meals this month to
children in need help them reach their
goal by ordering your next box at
goodranchers.comwalsh
goodranchers will donate a nutritious
meal to a child in need for every box
ordered through august 31st help them
donate 100 000 meals and
get 30 off plus free shipping at
goodranchers.com
walsh
all right lots of comments and you might
notice a theme in these comments i don't
know it's a little bit subtle but first
comment is you cannot just make a man a
giant walrus and not give it to him this
is disgusting hashtag give matt his
walrus katie says everyone at the daily
wire needs to be arrested for causing
matt walsh anxiety due to his lack of
giant walruses
crystal says
why can't i have my walrus matt is
asking the real questions in life
ross carpenter says knowing matt's wife
had never heard of reddit is the best
thing i've heard all week also matt if
you can't get your walrus then i cannot
support you as a theocratic dictator get
it done
jsan pizza man says if matt doesn't show
up on camera tomorrow with a giant plush
walrus the entire dw staff is canceled
hashtag give matt his walrus
the magic wish says i couldn't stop
laughing when matt said yeah i want my
walrus give the man as dang walrus
dustin says matt there's literally
nothing more important in the world than
getting your walrus the sweet baby gang
shall not rest until dw fulfills its
responsibility to our sweet daddy
um
marcelo says a thousand episodes second
set of twins what is a woman johnny the
walrus one million subscribers i mean
what's left just give sweet daddy walsh
the person of the year award right now
thanks for all you do well
what's left
marcelo is my walrus um which
i still have not been given as you can
see you can look around in this
beautiful studio and there's lots of
space in the studio it is quite spacious
okay this is this is not my car anymore
and it's not the closet they had me in
before um there's plenty of places where
a walrus would fit and yet if you could
see for yourself
no walrus is here
i do appreciate how the sweet baby gang
has mobilized around this issue um
and spoken out so passionately about
that it is very meaningful to me and i
assure you that and i'm but i'm going to
need you to continue
to cry out in one shared voice
give matt his walrus
uh the giant stuffed walrus was made for
me it belongs to me by all rights
and i will have my vengeance in this
life or the next
i will have my walrus in this life of
the next preferably in this life though
i will say i did make a mistake i have
to admit i made the mistake and i can't
believe it's like a rookie mistake i
can't believe i did this but really it
was just i was so i'm so excited about
the walrus and and and you know the
knowledge that eventually i will be
giving it and so i wanted to show my
wife i showed my wife a picture
of the giant walrus and said we're gonna
i'm bringing this home soon okay once i
find it i'm bringing this home
and she looked at it
and she said that if i bring that thing
home i could no longer ever complain
about all the pillows she buys
and i said this isn't a pillow it's a
walrus thank you and she said that the
walrus will take up a lot more room than
the pillows though and i said well
that's an incredibly reductive like
degrading way to look at the giant
stuffed walrus taking up room
there are many spaces in our home many
nooks and crannies that are not really
being used for anything why shouldn't
there be a walrus in those spaces so so
the better question is not like the
burden of proof isn't on me okay the
better question is
don't ask me well why do we need this
walrus no i think the question is why
don't we have one already okay we've
been married for almost 11 years and
through 11 years not once
have i brought a giant stuffed walrus
home and i bring one home in 11 years
and it's a problem
makes no sense
anyway doesn't matter i want my walrus
and i want it now and i will have it
today is a tuesday like no other because
this is the one thousandth episode of
the matt walsh show you know what they
say if you make woke leftists the object
of your contemptuous ridicule then
you'll never work a day in your life i
think that's a saying somewhere that's
true of the show and that's certainly
true when it comes to my documentary
what is a woman that has more than 5 000
audience ratings and raw tomatoes and
even five reviews from critics who are
brave enough to touch it uh this month
we um the month rather that we released
what is a woman the daily wire gained
more members than at any other time in
our history just goes to show that if
you make something worth watching unlike
most hollywood movies and drag queen
story hours everything else people will
watch in droves if you haven't seen it
yet go to what is a woman dot com to
watch right now that's what is a woman
dot com now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
well
i wanted to leave a little extra time
for this today um an important issue
slightly more important than the the
walrus if anything could be
back in may
a trans activist an influencer by the
name of eli ehrlich
announced a felony conspiracy on
instagram ehrlich excitedly told 40 000
plus followers about a brilliant plan to
circumvent state laws banning doctors
prescribing hormones to gender confuse
minors ehrlich's genius scheme which was
laid out in strenuous detail and
remained published on instagram for
nearly three months before libs of tick
tock finally noticed it and reposted it
to twitter
the scheme was to gather leftover
prescription hormone pills and mail them
to anyone who wants them
no questions asked we're told
here was the actual uh post it said
there are over 20 states trying to
criminalize hormone therapy particularly
for trans youth so my friends and i had
an idea
sending out our extra prescriptions
around the country if you need hormones
i'm working with a distribution network
to get you access everything is free no
questions asked we have hundreds of
doses of testosterone
estradiol
and
spironolactone i think is whatever it is
all that is available right now all are
prescribed by doctors and unused each
package comes with information on dosage
obtaining blood work etc i realize this
is a band-aid solution we need full
access to affirmative medical medical
care for professionals immediately
however missing a single dose of
hormones can be devastating especially
for trans teens and those new to
hormones these laws are outrageous and i
can't wait for them to be overturned in
the meantime dm me if you need hrt or if
you have over over prescribed hormones
that you'd like to send out
now in response to a question posed by a
follower erlich confirmed that this
black market drug network can
realistically ship to anywhere in north
america
which means that the drug smuggling
operation is international
this is not a new thing either in
september ehrlich made something of an
anniversary post on instagram
celebrating 11 years on hormones in
commemoration of the big event and as a
wise old trans sage dispensing morsels
of wisdom ehrlich shared 11 mantras for
hormone use and mantra 6 was
redistribute your extra hormones to
people who can't access slash afford
them
this mantra by the way was explained in
a youtube video posted a few months
earlier where ehrlich offers what looks
and sounds like a confession that you'd
hear during the plea bargain phase at
trial
uh let's listen
every month for the past several years
i've ordered a double dose of hormones
and testosterone blockers
i save all the extra pills for my best
friends my closest lovers and my worst
enemies
i just hope these little pills can bring
some joy into their life i have the
opportunity to give life-saving
medication to people who need it and it
basically costs me nothing
a few months ago i posted on instagram
asking for testosterone for a friend who
actually already had a prescription his
doctor was out of town and he couldn't
get a new one
within hours my story was taken down and
i received a warning by the
administrators now of course i know it's
against instagram rules to share
substances and i wasn't particularly
surprised that it was removed
but i was still upset
so yeah i know it's illegal duh
so is changing my social security to
female without medical treatment so was
crossing the street outside my apartment
instead of using the crosswalk
oh yeah i mean jaywalking is exactly
like
trafficking in prescription pills
illegally
right now in that video having
apparently only just developed this
fetish for announcing federal crimes on
the internet ehrlich was a little more
cautious there's a disclaimer quote
unquote early on claiming that the whole
thing is merely hypothetical
but after getting a little taste of
self-incrimination and having apparently
enjoyed it so much early became far more
brash and bold in subsequent
pronouncements leading up finally to the
instagram announcement in which the
whole drug distribution enterprise is
laid out in detail
yet
as acknowledged in the clip that we just
played
all of this is illegal it is in fact so
illegal that it would be impossible for
me to count all the laws that it breaks
it is illegal to share your prescription
medication with anyone who it was not
prescribed for
it is illegal to facilitate the exchange
of other people's prescription drugs it
is illegal to ship controlled substances
through the mail it is illegal to
distribute drugs across state lines it
is illegal to send them to other
countries
all of these drugs are illegal for
anyone who is not a doctor or pharmacist
to distribute
period
and for good reason
the substance is being shipped across
the country by erlich's ragtag group of
drug peddlers are dangerous potent laden
with potentially severe side effects and
they make irreversible changes to your
body
in participating in this scheme not just
participating but organizing it ehrlich
has violated dozens of state laws
federal laws and international laws
making the perp here
eligible for decades in federal prison
this has been done
and talked about openly on every
available platform yet up to this moment
there has been not so much as an
instagram suspension in response
much less a raid by the dea
why
well because eli ehrlich is in a
privileged class the most privileged
class that has ever existed in the west
that's why the confessed drug trafficker
responded so brazenly when i first
started tweeting about this issue on
friday after libs of tick tock reported
on it
um
and i started tweeting about it and
talking about it and uh from ehrlich
there was never any denial
still to this point no denial
none
instead ehrlich defended the criminal
activity telling me that these drugs are
life-saving medications
which is just more confirmation that
you're doing what it appears that you're
doing which is illegally uh distributing
the drugs when i remarked that this
response may be the first time in my
life that someone has tried to dunk on
me by publicly confessing to a federal
crime erlich replied it's an honor matt
ehrlich also thanked us for advertising
quote unquote the trafficking operation
and fully embraced the label drug
smuggler
said it might go in the in the
bio now it should be noted for what it's
worth that ehrlich was slightly less
excited to embrace the label accused
sexual abuser threatening to sue me for
libel when i repost when i reposted
reports from other outlets noting that
ehrlich has along with being a confessed
drug smuggler uh has indeed been accused
of sexual assault by multiple alleged
victims
and you know that's that's a fact that's
that's the news there that's that the
accusation has been made
i don't know if it's true or not but
there was the accusations
so i suppose we can add the law to the
list of things this person does not
begin to understand
thinking that i could be sued for libel
for reposting a news report
but no surprise coming from someone who
casually captions their selfies with
criminal conspiracy confessions
but go ahead and file your lawsuit eli i
have
please do i have a feeling that
discovery might be a very interesting
process
now
eli i admit that um
you have some justification for being so
brazen
after all you've never been held
accountable for anything in your entire
life
you are privileged and spoiled and
literally never in your life have you
been held accountable for anything
so why should that change now i mean why
should justice catch up with you now you
ask
well
part of the reason why people like you
skate by enjoying your own set of rules
is that so often
people like the rest of us
have grown to simply accept this absurd
state of affairs there's no reason why
the system would punish someone like you
if if nobody even bothers to demand it
because we assume it's not going to
happen
and maybe that assumption will be
correct maybe nothing much will happen
even if we do demand it
or maybe you would actually be made to
face some sort of consequence for the
first time in your life either way
we're going to find out
because i am not going to simply accept
that being trans makes you above the law
even less am i going to accept the
illegal distribution of dangerous drugs
to minors
i'm not going to let this go or shrug my
shoulder and say well nothing we could
do and move on
uh no
no more of that
i'm going to use the resources at my
disposal which are considerably greater
than the resources at your disposal to
make sure that justice is done here
why
well because
you're distributing dangerous drugs to
minors across the country and this is
only the tip of the iceberg thanks to
predators like yourself kids have many
avenues for obtaining these substances
without any doctor's approval much less
parental consent
this is what parents have to worry about
now that their children will in secret
begin to medically transition with the
help of drugs they obtained through
instagram
now i doubt that you're the country's
most prolific illegal distributor of
prescription drugs but you are the one
that we're going to make an example of
because we have to start somewhere
also eli i should note that i just don't
like your attitude i think you need some
humility in your life
and i i am generous enough to help you
develop that virtue
so
here's what's going to happen
i want anyone concerned about this
criminal activity to do the responsible
thing
and report it to the relevant
authorities if you see something say
something how many times have we been
told that
and let's start with the dea
you can easily find the link on google
but here is the url we'll put it up on
the screen for you
dea.gov
submit dash tip
from there you can submit a tip either
anonymously or not it's up to you
and you can note that there is someone
by the name of eli ehrlich who has
announced an intention
to participate in the illegal
distribution of prescription drugs
across the country
we're not finished ehrlich despite not
understanding math statistics the law or
for that matter human biology is a phd
candidate at the university of
california santa cruz
the university ought to know
and ought to act upon the fact that one
of their phds is an emitted drug
trafficker
so yesterday i reached out personally to
the chancellor of the university cynthia
kayla reeve to ask her about this matter
and i haven't heard back yet
now i'm going to give her the rest of
today to respond
and to explain what steps are being
taken to address this very troubling
situation but if i still could not get a
hold of her after today then it will be
my duty and responsibility as a citizen
to share the publicly available contact
information for the university
administration and encourage all of my
thousands of listeners and viewers and
the millions who follow me on social
media to call an email demanding that
the university take action
i hope it doesn't come to that and but
but i have a feeling that it will after
all the university said nothing earlier
in the summer when ehrlich posted a
tweet calling for the assassination of
supreme court justices
they remind they remain silent then too
but silence will not be an option
anymore
what is it that they say again oh a
silence is violence
we're not done yet ehrlich having used
social media and instagram in particular
to coordinate this criminal activity
should be indefinitely suspended there
has rarely been a more deserving
candidate for d-platforming as this
account is an actual danger to children
reason enough for a permanent ban
so we'll walk you through the steps to
file your report with instagram uh you
go to instagram first go to eli
ehrlich's page then hit the three little
dots at the top right of the screen and
select report and from there select
report account and then select it's
posting content that shouldn't be on
instagram and then select sale of
illegal or regulated goods and finally
drugs
everyone listening to me right now
should do that
what should happen from here is that
eli is kicked out of school
de-platformed arrested and put under
criminal investigation by both federal
and state authorities that's what should
happen
that would be the just and right
result here
will any of that happen
well there's only one way to find out
and even if every institution decides to
accept ehrlich's trans your way out of
jail free card a very distinct
possibility after all these institutions
are ideologically ideologically captured
as previously established
but even still
at least by using all of our platforms
to amplify this story we can ensure that
whenever anyone googles this person in
the future potential employers or
anybody else they will immediately see
that eli ehrlich is a confessed drug
peddler
this is already working we've already
prompted several news outlets including
fox to cover the scandal
and um we're going to continue because
we can make sure that this creep
is branded by these admitted crimes
for eternity
and that's something at least
but most of all
we can send a message that we do not
accept the hierarchy that our society
has put in place we are not going to bow
our heads submissively as the privileged
classes break the law and harm our
children at will
we're just not
we're going to fight back
and that's what this is and that is also
why eli ehrlich who again has confessed
to distributing drugs illegally across
the country to minors is
canceled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matte wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavel dowsky
our associate producer is mckenna waters
the show is edited by jeff tomlin our
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is done by cherokee heart the
matte wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 22.